hey Megan I thought that I have been  clear about the number of buttons that  can be unbuttoned are you body shaming  her right now Jeremy come on it's winter  can we put dancer and prancer back and  their stable if I hear you like your  stripper girlfriend put my children on  her motorcycle one more time I will gone  girl you so hard you're God I'm just  going to go in okay so are you gonna be  inviting your fake girlfriend to the  holiday party later I mean just one make  sure you have time to inflator  [Applause]  this party has to rock did you rent a  live baby what it's cheaper than you  think Savannah oh my gosh you guys are  gonna have so much fun tonight I'm not  even getting County because we're  friends right yeah we're not oh my god  [Applause]  oh I'm okay Merry Christmas you do not  want to die at the hands of Lululemon  here be real embarrassing for you you're  a large guy and she's made a nothing but  salad in SmartWater nope no tap out  [Applause]  [Music]  you